for more than two weeks the Saudis
insisted nothing untoward happened in
this building the Jamal keshavjee walked
in and walked out again alive
now this Salma Hannah Ebola am be merula
an admission the journalist is in fact
dead and the Saudis killed him but does
their story add up and will it convince
anyone one of you love him oh Allah
it requires believing that Jamarcus
Shoji a mild-mannered journalist fought
a fist fight in the consulate that led
to his death with a number of other men
the Saudi government says 18 people have
been arrested and are being investigated
among them it's thought at least some of
the 15 agents Turks say was sent to
Istanbul to deal with keshavjee and a
high-ranking intelligence official
general s Seri Turkish officials say
they have evidence keshavjee was
tortured killed and dismembered a very
different story from the Saudi version
of events Saudi Arabia has been a great
ally but what happened is unacceptable I
would prefer if there is going to be
some form of sanction or what we may
determine to do if anything because this
was a lot of people they're talking
about and people pretty high up but I
would prefer that we don't use as
retribution cancelling 110 billion
dollars worth of work Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman emerges unscathed
for now appointed head of a new
committee to restructure Saudi
intelligence in the wake of the debacle
the affair has already damaged his
reputation as both competent ruler and
reformer
and key questions remain will allies
swallow the story or will America press
on with sanctions while the Turks
produce evidence to the contrary and if
this is the truth
why did Saudis lie for two and a half
weeks before changing their story
Dominik Waghorn sky news in Riyadh